good morning to you mr. Hancock good
morning how are you very well thank you
I've just been looking across social
media this morning you love Luton that
James cleverly thrown his hat into the
ring today so lots of Tory people
tweeting this morning one of them
Dominic Rob he's just tweeted your
pledge will clean campaigning pledge
signed by Dominic Raab yourself Sajid
Javid I'm just looking at that top one
there that caught my attention I will
not speak ill of my fellow conservatives
then I pick up a copy of Financial Times
this morning in which he have some very
interesting language in reference to
Boris Johnson who wants it's alleged
said Fiddlesticks to business you can
see what I did there any response you've
said to the people who say Fiddlesticks
to business I say Fiddlesticks
fiddlesticks business what the
Fiddlesticks is going on well I think
that it's really clear I will be very
robust in making the case for what I
believe in and I believe very strongly
that we need to support business to
create jobs because that is the source
of prosperity for our country and I
think that the Conservative Party is
nothing if we don't crack business we
need to back business not bash business
but I won't make this personal right
that all of the different you're saying
you're gonna be very robust in in you
know campaigning and about brexit but
you're not being very robust in keeping
your pledges already that pledge was
less than 24 hours old and you've broken
it no on the contrary I will be very
robust in a policy debate in debate
about the language that we use but I'm
not going to make any personal attacks
on people's personalities and undertake
that sort of negative campaigning people
who say Fiddlesticks business
I say Fiddlesticks too Fiddlesticks
business because I am a very strong
supporter of supporting our businesses
large and small because that's where
prosperity comes from and we as a party
need to be backing them in policy and in
language but yeah I
like all of the candidates who are
standing I look forward to working with
them I very much hope that they will
work for me as Prime Minister but if one
of them should win then I'd be very
happy to serve it there is a important
difference and in politics it's really
important we get this right we must have
robust debate that's important but we
must do it about the issues and the
issue I was talking about is the ice
support business
okay robust debate but with no swear
words please if you do make it to the
live debates particularly amongst the
final tea here on Sky News we'll have
none of that language please mr. Hancock
and would you support any qualities in
our newspaper so okay okay so you'd say
you can you can use that language okay
let's talk about No Deal would you
support a candidate that supports No
Deal well I don't think that leaving the
EU with No Deal
is a credible policy choice for any
others Prime Minister because the House
of Commons has already stopped it once
you know they changed the Constitution
to stop it ahead of the 29th of March
and passed a law against the
government's wishes which hasn't
happened for hundreds of years and the
speaker only yesterday made clear that
whether we like it or not that he would
allow the Commons to have it say again
now my view is that we need to leave the
European Union with a deal on or before
the 31st of October I still think that
is deliverable and it's deliverable by
making sure that we get a mandate to
change and to deliver it so that Tory
MPs come in behind a deal and that we
negotiate a different future agreement
with the European Union how are you
gonna do that because your hashtag is
let's move forward and from what I can
tell that's reading about your
leadership campaign you're essentially
backing Teresa Mays deal or have I got
that wrong do you think you can go back
and renegotiate with EU leaders I think
that we bear very clear that we can have
discussions about negotiate on the
future arrangements
what the long term drunkard Yunker said
it's crystal clear that there will be no
renegotiation so how are you going to
renegotiate of the withdrawal agreement
so there's two parts to this the one is
the agreement with on which we actually
leave the EU and they say that they
won't renegotiate that and we shall see
but the the other part where they're
clear they they will negotiate is on the
future arrangements on the and what our
long-term relationship with Europe is
like and that's the important one
ultimately and that's what we need to
get on to discussing and they're up for
that debate so I think is by making
changes there that we can bring the
Conservative Party together with a
mandate because whoever is elected and I
very much hope it will be me
whoever's elected will have the support
of the Conservative Party will have been
through this big debate and come round a
view and we should back that view to
deliver brexit and then as I say let's
move forward
okay and let's move forward and just
talk about and summing it up for people
because obviously there's a lot of words
and people just want to know in a
nutshell let's do it yes or no answer to
No Deal
yes or no well it's not a policy choice
that's available
okay renegotiation yes second referendum
nope okay fine and I just want to ask as
well in terms of your job as health
secretary spoke to you very passionately
last week about social care and what
you're going to do to help those people
what would you say to those families you
made promises to who you are essentially
now leaving to try and get the top job
oh well as a prime minister I would
absolutely ensure that this work
continued and is strengthened I mean
I've been deeply affected by talking to
the families of those who are locked up
in care and in some cases they have to
be but in many cases okay thank you